so uh CNN's favorite resident pool boy
in chief Chris Cuomo savanna boy he was
having a debate with with Ben Ferguson
and I wanted to run through these clips
because I think that Chris Cuomo
statements here on this Mac bags in the
state wrestling title and the issue of
gender and biology it's very it's very
typical of how today's regressive left
argues these type of issues let's go
clip one kind of hormone that this kid
is given is the minimum standard they
can give to replicate the output of a
boy so it's not like a super amount of
testosterone it's not like these kids
are going to be superhuman it is the
opposite they are given the minimum
scientifically that is the outcome if
you look and do the research as I have
you'll see that yeah I mean if a Gavin
said we're saying the exact same thing
as like it's just the it's only the
amount required to make her like a boy
so she could beat the [ __ ] out of girls
we're gonna yeah I don't understand so I
guess oh he's talking about science here
he says if you've done the research
right so Chris como wants to talk about
sensual let's look at the size let's
look at the average testosterone levels
for females so a female a seventeen year
old girl is somewhere around the fifty
to seventy five nanograms per deciliter
this is what they used I don't I know
people will try and fact-check me we can
talk about this or free testosterone the
ratios are going to be quite similar so
fifty milligrams per deciliter the
average boy at 17 if you look at here
from the Mayo Clinic can be 300 to 1200
and 300 would actually be very very low
warranting supplementation so the
average if you look there you take the
mean will be somewhere around the 800
mark for a 17 year old boy that's on
your testosterone level it's our highest
so let's take that number 50 nanograms
per deciliter for a girl - 800 for a
male so the minimum required dose to
bring that girl to the kind of hormonal
profile that a male has would be low and
eight to ten more like 12 to 15 times
the amount and for context but this is
superhuman when he does not remember
competing as a girl
this is superhuman because when you look
at actual when we talk about scale
and how much we complain Barry Bonds
Mark McGwire athletes and sports they
don't enjoy anywhere we're talking about
12 to 15 10 to 15 times the amount of
boy over a girl Barry Bonds or these
juiced to the gills mr. Olympia's they
might be in the top upper 1000 mm really
really high we can see this might get
you to the 3000 nanogram per deciliter
if you look at those strongmen power
lifters and that's what we call super
physiological dosage meaning a dose that
is above anything that a human could
create so the ratio for a man on
steroids would be maybe three times or
say the multiple would be three times
the amount of the average man on a
really strong day on an average day the
lowest possible dosage required to take
little Mack bags to the average boy
level or lowest boy level would be a
minimum of eight times the hormone
testosterone responsible for not only
not only not only bone density cartilage
ligaments muscle tissue the way the rest
of your hormones respond your hormones
are giant they will also bring tissue
we'll get into with the trans issue men
have big on brain some may call these
that's significant significant some some
also may call them a statistical
advantage this is yes the issue is
acceptance if this state allowed this
kid to wrestle against boys which is
what he wants we wouldn't be talking
about this case right now it's now been
accepted I see it was about science it
was about science or if you've done the
research on science now the issue is
about acceptance well okay how about
this how about you Chris Cuomo accept
the science as we have this clip I think
we have it from morning grinders I
forgot to run that clip let's accept the
science we did as seen here by noted
weakling Jarrod vs. ha ha ha ha cooking
Cortney scoffs roll clip just imagine
what you could do and people who share
your idea are using misinformation and
mythology here the idea of illness
inform a horse it is because the idea
that that I have a
in their face my twelve-year-old
daughter she's going to have genitals
waved in her face usually this would be
a straw man except in the sport of
wrestling you can quite literally have
genitals I'm tapping out right there
ha ha ha I'm done he took a trauma and
they did a real one you did a chance
stop losing okay anyways it goes under
this he says your technique about
genitals in the face so we've gone from
science to acceptance to someone about
genitals in the face now Chris Cuomo
goes on to debate with this strategy
what happens when the girl identifies as
a boy and wants to go to the boys locker
room or vice versa
to play into the fear and for you to say
that there are none on the right who are
making about what I'm saying is is
demonstrably false so we go from the
science if you've them to science
there's no way to debate with someone
like this now and I we believe in always
trying to have an idea a form of ideas
discussion of ideas absolutely I don't
believe you should ever absolve yourself
of arguing ideas but how can you argue
and I with Michael Ian Black right here
how can you argue this on a on a
platform of ideas if you've them a
science research as violent as I've been
the science research okay well this with
the science is it's not about science
right exceptions penises in your face
what you can't say that not a single
right wing person has ever sent me a
picture of a penis in a face Donald
Trump that clip go to my Twitter feed
there there you know they are putting
barriers of my face on a guy exposing
himself to a twelve-year-old girl
go to my Twitter feed oh you can imagine
if I might be my twitter the advances
nobody has more minors more people put
penises all over my face
assisted normal Dandridge news look at
my Twitter feed brother and we did look
at a Twitter feed this is the tweet in
question that's so much a prick by the
way non-gay Jared and I get worse on our
lunch break
screw it go through that's a very very
pain the Twitter slant so again it goes
from science let's I hate to be
repetitive here science to acceptance to
balls on face - are you denying that any
right-wing person has ever said any
transphobic - now look at my Twitter
feed and actually we did we had Jared do
his research you went on a Twitter feed
anymore I mean there's not a whole lot
there to see it's mostly tame okay well
I see what can happen there I could see
why he could be perturbed how did this
is why you're getting so personal crisp
jet hack
alright here's his next argument you
should let these kids be where they're
most comfortable this is about
accommodation I thought it was about
science no they don't want the kid to
have what he wants so we're over seeing
him to wrestle our girls you don't want
the care to use the bathroom they want
through it because you don't like it
based on your tradition I'm saying let's
write it is over there aren't no
delivers we left his parenting and
conservative parenting right you know
the little kid wants is the kid was they
critical mother kind of guy would have
kidding man I want cotton candy and I
want a cookie and I want I want I want
me know now now now and Chris comes like
okay let me see well I can accommodate
that my father like dad yeah I want to
use the ladies room no you don't give
kids everything that they love you
specifically abuse the transgender
doesn't happen on a whim it's a
continuum of time and hormones and pain
and anxiety and I challenge you and
everybody was listening to go find me a
case of indecent exposure by a
transgender person in a bathroom it
doesn't happen it happens all the time
haven't we written about it a lot of
credit a comment happens all the time
one happened in target there was the
incident Seattle what actually that guy
was just gaming the system he's kind of
my hero and by the way it doesn't it
doesn't happen I want to happens over
time the last season of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians ended and four months
later Bruce Jenner was Caitlyn so let's
stay real here it's not this haven't
needed to happen over the course of
years no it can happen really quickly
certainly as far as we're used to if you
had a family member who over the course
of the summer or your kid you know your
friends you go to summer camp if you
have some friends you only see in school
and you're naturally
over the summer and you come back as I
go Oh Charles okay you're a woman now
all right took me long to get my CDL
very permit it take longer it takes
longer to get a revolver in New Jersey
than it does to change your sex on your
driver's license I think we have one
last clip right and if you look at the
data the only thing that you accomplish
by doing what you say is traditional is
that you scar these kids as an other and
their rates of depression and suicide
and non acceptance go up and that last
conclusion is so perfect of everything
that's happened here was about science
and then it was about comfort and then
it was about accept right here he goes
the rates of depression the rates of
suicide okay okay let's talk about that
that's science and unacceptance ah not a
metric it's like let's talk about the
rate of average income okay of average
degrees or average levels of education
yes and what people's broken dreams are
you can't put them in the same thing or
how I let it be like saying hey this mug
is if it's 16-ounce is great that can
fit an entire beer which tends to be 12
fluid ounces yes also how much do you
personally enjoy the flavor in that mug
on a scale from one to ten the answer
for mug club is always ten by ten as
well because they're taking two things
that are scientifically observable that
have metrics you can look at depression
you can look at suicide and you know
what by the way before we get to
unacceptance let's look at that 98% of
confused boys and 88% of confused girls
eventually accept their gender after
puberty
that's something the less I want to talk
about let's talk about the suicide rates
thirty percent of transgender youth
report at least one suicide attempt 42%
report in self-injury as they get older
41% a temp in suicide rate it's at least
that high even after the sex hormone
replacement therapy even after the sex
change if they go through the most
transgenders don't so we're talking
about unacceptance we won't talk about
other and you won't talk about helping
kids how about actually getting them the
help that they need because
statistically if you look at the science
by the way gender has no basis in
biology whatsoever as seen by chris
cuomo trying to go from france i read
this to balls on your face to my twitter
feed he has no argument he has no leg to
stand on so we go to this idea of
acceptance as though that's ultimately
the most important value and so it's
somehow virtuous to accept everything
regardless of the outcome when we know
that you are putting these kids
particularly men when you're giving them
a stir dinner if you're giving women
unnatural levels of testosterone you
could be putting them into a very
shallow cancerous grave brought on by
early suicide these people need help any
way you look at it the transgender
community is not mentally healthy I'm
not saying that it's necessarily a
mental illness but if you care about the
group let's actually try to get to a
solution instead of as you guys hate
with Big Pharma throwing drugs throwing
hormones at it and talking about balls
on the face but instead we can't talk
about science right it because it's
about accommodation apparently Chris
Cuomo skipped that science class
[Music]
if you like this clip you're like most
of the Internet you have a short
attention span but it was taken from the
full show you can see it in the box
playing next to me that's once a week on
Thursdays full one and a half hour show
or you can join the Mudd Club for the
daily show let's take some of that off
YouTube because they're monitoring us